paul kelly que l'autre donc famille
vedova li vé novelis est d'origine
italienne
oui exactement j'adore ça avec mon père
est italien ouais bien sûr adoula
c'était votre délire vous en chanteur
justin bieber justin bieber enfant
j'étais déguisé
what you to mean time and bear berruyer
errait comme une âme inc menthol mentos
prestataires ses moteurs mais il est pas
loin de maxime daigneault met en doute
je suis à me tuer c'est justin beiber
relooker un petit peu max et ce sera
parfait look et savannah des superbes
styliste qui nous habite elle habite
toujours dans le rouge
je suis beaucoup mieux qu'il ya trois
ans déjà assez bien moins bien que dans
trois ans bah alors attention vous
pouvez lire et dégueulasse ans je vous
le dis attention je vais vérifier ça aux
graves savais que je voulais même très
fort